there's this neuroscientist
neuropsychologist named el conan
goldberg and goldberg was a student of
alexander Luria and alexander Luria was
a russian neuropsychologist perhaps the
foremost neuropsychologist of the mid to
late 20th century and he had students
Sokolov in vineger dov'è who discovered
the orienting reflex for example the
orienting reflex is the reflex that
Orient's you when something anomalous
interferes with your goal directed
behavior it's a major discovery like one
of the one of the four or five most
important discoveries that have ever
been made in in in psychology I would
say certainly in neuroscience so Luria
was a big deal and he was the first
person who really established the
functional role of the prefrontal cortex
as well so and he had it very nice
overall view of how the brain function
his book was written in 1980 and it's
still there's still loss in it that's
really useful which is pretty strange
for a science that's advanced that
quickly
anyways so Goldberg came from a great
pedigree I believe Luria's teacher was
Pavlov if I remember correctly so
anyways
Goldberg you know you hear some of you
may have heard the idea that the left
hemisphere is more or linguistic than
the right hemisphere is that left
hemisphere is specialized for language
and the right hemisphere is specialized
for nonverbal imagistic communication
the left hemisphere has a pretty well
organized microstructure and the right
hemisphere is more diffuse as well and
that's true in left-handed males in
particular so the circuitry can be
switched around a bit but it's okay the
modules are basically the same although
they can be moved a little bit but
Goldberg thought that it isn't language
versus non language it's routine versus
novelty and so the left hemisphere and
there's a neuropsychologist physician
named Ramachandran who's done some very
interesting work
that's pertinent to this maybe I'll tell
you a story about him anyways Goldberg
believed that the right hemisphere say
you have very old systems underneath
both both cortical hemispheres that do
things like respond to anomaly to the
thing that doesn't fit to the predator
in the distance some of that's
extraordinarily fast so that would be
like a snake reflex that can move you
away from a snake in less time than it
takes the snake to bite and it's really
a reflex it doesn't even hit your brain
it's really super fast and then there's
a defensive Crouch that's that's
instantiated higher up in the nervous
system but that's still remarkably fast
and then there's fear as an emotion and
and the orientation of attention and
then there's the cognitive processing
and that all streams out across a time
span right and maybe that time span is
half a second so and that's really a
long time if something is attacking you
so you got it those initial responses
are quite primitive but they're
extraordinarily fast all right so
there's subcortical structures that
orient you towards novelty and prepare
you for for freezing or for attending
and the right hemisphere seems to be
dominated by those systems so imagine
that what happens is that something
threatens you you orient towards it
the right hemisphere produces a bunch of
images about what it might be
so imagine that's what happens when the
child is afraid of the dark
the child's on the bed they're afraid of
the dark they're crouched because
they're frozen like a prey animal and
their right hemisphere is producing
monsters to inhabit the darkness that
are the child's hypotheses about what
might be out there okay because that's
what you want to know right you want to
know what's out there and then you want
to know what to do about it I can tell
you two kids dreams that are sort of
relevant to that so when my daughter was
about three she came into the bedroom
that my wife and I had and she was
crying she'd had a nightmare and she
said that she saw a stream and there was
garbage all over the stream and she
didn't like that and so I sat her down
okay so imagine the stream with the
garbage in it now imagine that you're
taking the garbage out and throwing it
in the garbage bin and so she and I got
her to like visualize that because that
kind of puts her back in the semi dream
state and then she cleaned up the mess
and then she could go off to sleep
now you you could tell the child don't
worry about the dream isn't real that's
not that's true because it's not real
like other daytime things are but it's
not like it's not real it's a dream like
a dream is real it's just not the same
kind of real and so what I did with her
was to indicate to her practically that
if she saw something a normal us
something that was out of place right
something that was a mess that it was
within her capacity to set it right okay
and so okay so now your right hemisphere
tells you what monsters might inhabit
the darkness now what you have to do is
figure out there's two things you have
to figure out one is what to do about a
given monster and now there is to do
what about is to figure out what to do
about the class of all possible monsters
right that's a whole different thing
that's something that only human beings
are capable of that level of abstraction
right and so what you might do about a
particular monster is hide or go out and
get rid of it it was just an actual
animal right but that doesn't help
because there's all the other potential
predators that are still there and so
maybe you can go hon to all them down
but that doesn't help either because you
you can't hunt them all down it's not or
it's not very likely anyways so instead
what you have to do is figure out how to
configure yourself so that you're in the
best possible position to fight off the
monsters when they come that's your best
bet